COLORADO AVALANCHE.
TONIGHT IS THE FINN
HERE.
KEEP AN EYE E
THERE'S
GOAL!OUND THE
DEFENDER, MALE.
AND THAT IS WHAT
OPENS UP THE
GET THROUGH.
HAYTON TAKING A LEFT.
AND C STAAL
GETTING PHYSICAL
BEHIND
ANANDD L LOOOOK,K,
SSCCOROREEDD! ! ZZININGS
JJAKAKOOB B WWITITHH  H
OFOF  TTHEHE  GAGAMEME.
HHE E HAHAS S EAEATTEEN
SHSHOORRT T SSHHOWOWIIN.
KNKNOOCCKEKEDD  DODOWWN
THTHE E CCOYOYOOTTESES
OFOFFF. .
NUNUMBMBEER R 114 4 OON
TTHHEREREE. .
HHEEAVAV
SSCCOROREE! ! K K WWHHO
A A FOFOLLLLOWOW--UPUP
HEHE  RREAEALLLLY Y THT
AALLL-L-STSTAARRSS. .
NNOOW W RRIGIGHHTT I IN
KKEEEEP P AAN N EEYEYE
HHE E GEGETTS S THTHEE
AANNDD T THHEEN N HHE E
OOF F ----  EEYYE E OOFF
HHIIMM. .
>>> > TWTWOO MOMORRE E
AATTTTEMEMPPTTS S
CCLLAYAYTTOON N KKELELL.
LLEDEDDDY Y SHSHOOOOT T
HHE E TATAKEKESS  A A
BLBLOCOCKIKINGNG I ITT.
GEGETTSS